hello in a very warm welcome indeed to
quadriga coming to you from the heart of
Berlin and suddenly it seems there is a
new mood in German politics voters are
going green in numbers in recent opinion
polls the environmentalists have for the
first time ever hosted Angela Merkel's
conservative Christian Democrats as the
country's most popular party and there's
growing talk that the next Chancellor
could even be agreeing so our question
this week on quadriga
is the greens Germany's new number one
and to discuss that question I'm joined
here in the studio by Professor Wolfgang
Merkel from the Berlin Social Science
Center who says the greens are the party
of the privileged and as such their
natural upper limit may be touched at
20% also witnesses prominent business
journalist and commentator us allah
Biden felt who believes no other party
has struggled as much as the Greens to
accept the spirit of the market economy
interesting and a very warm welcome to
to DW so Maximilian akashic who is a
political correspondent the Deutsche
Welle keeps a close eye on the greens
and Maxie argues that the Greens must
choose between purity and breaths
they can't please everyone she adds
interesting thank you for those three
statements at the top of the show first
question goes to Maxie Maxie how green
is Germany I think Germany is getting
greener every election we see that in
especially least eight elections the
last couple years we've seen that in
Bavaria last year where the Greens have
become the second biggest fourth in the
Marion Parliament which was
traditionally very conservative and
reigned by Merkel's sister party the
Bavarian conservatives we've seen that
also in hatha one of the other
conservative strongholds where the
Greens gain significantly they're
getting a foothold in almost every of
German estates the question is how ready
are they going to be governing these
states how willing are they going to be
governing states and is this still a
debate we only see in the West because
we all have a couple elections coming up
in eastern Germany and the Greens
haven't gained quite a foot there yet
though Levin felt the reason I'm asking
about how green is Germany is because
you will know that people outside
Germany are always asking whether
they're they're aware that Germany
a long environmentalist green tradition
and I wonder whether you believe that
that that image of Germany still stands
up is still valid it is climate change
protection has moved in the middle into
the mainstream within the last month and
the I think that the Green Party's
success is in some kind you can you can
understand it as the movement of climate
change protections within the families
within a broader society we have
professor Merkel the question is I
suppose the success of the greens that
is now been on that they've been on the
rise as maxim was pointing out for quite
some time is it here to say because
they've been there they've been here
before and have faded back to becoming a
10-15 percent party okay are they here
to stay this time as one of Germany's
leading forces and I'm a bit more
cautious about these polls we are
reading and present polls are polls
elections are elections and by the way
European elections are different from
national elections in national election
the people will vote more for party
whether not only have trust and have
sympathies but they must think that they
are able to govern and if we are looking
to the two people at the top of the
greens we would immediately say they do
not have any experience in governing and
to Trump from the top of the party into
the main offices of the country it's a
long way to go and this will be in the
perception of the voters as well okay
we'll talk about those two potential
leaders in a minute but just you you
characterize the greens as a polity of
privilege that sounds very dismissive no
it's not and it's simply empirical this
is the empirical truth we know the
Greens have the electorate where you
find most of the formerly very good
educated people and this is one reason
why I'm also sceptic
that the Koreans will really jump at the
top of our party system they draw
extensively on the voters in
metropolitan and urban cities and where
you find well-educated middle classes
and this is unlimited electorate they do
not have any crush on the voters of the
lower third of the Society says there is
a new dynamic in German policy she says
the pattern of German politics is
changing and he says the Greens can
harness that dynamic can create become a
broader based party yes and they will
just just one one sentence yes they will
try to do it and we cannot explain the
rise of the greens without the steep
decline of the to catch all parties the
CDU and the SPD they are to some extent
blood donors to understand to the cream
one of the one explanation is that
people are fed up with them the two
government party see experience them for
10 12 14 years now and the two players
that make up angular the grand coalition
and people have had up with that and one
the one one part of voters turned to the
greens and the other other part turns to
the the right-wingers I think exactly
the way we have to look currently where
the electorate is moving is going to
give us an indication as you say how the
Greens can develop because as much as
they're taking blood as you called it
from the centre left and right
conservative and Democratic parties
they're also letting blood to the left
so what we've seen in the national
election 2017 is that as much as the
Greens had gained votes they also lost a
couple of votes to the left especially
in these metropolitan areas and in these
state elections where we have a much
more rural community but we also see the
Greens of seeding we can feel a get a
bit of a feeling for the potential they
can have with the lesser elitist part of
the German electorate and I think that
is why the upcoming elections in the
east of Germany will be especially
interesting because there we will have
the least of this class
Green electorate and this is where they
need to start their actual convincing of
a broader electorate and if they will
succeed there but the time of big
parties is drawing to an end in you and
Europe we will not find these for
expertise we used to have for the folks
patine and this time is more or less
over you do not find very many in Europe
anymore and the Greens will not become
the new catch-all party in Germany let's
get some pictures first of all and then
come back to that theme yeah because as
we've seen the Greens go right back to
the 1980s and for many there's one
moment in particular when they really
established themselves on the national
radar here it is white sneakers it's an
unforgettable image Joschka Fischer
taking his oath of office as the Green
Party's first ever Minister he was
making a provocative statement with the
shoes yet for many it was proof that the
greens weren't to be taken seriously but
no one's saying that anymore while the
party has enjoyed successes in the past
it's now more popular than ever
mainly thanks to its likeable leaders on
Alena bear Bach and Beth pabich young
feisty and trustworthy they're
politicians who aren't afraid of taking
on responsibility for totin even bassam
entrepreneurs to the unemployed from
young to old people are voting for the
Greens for us that means it's our duty
to communicate and operationalize our
policies developed when we were in a
minority position so that they find
broad public support interesting
research of the American interesting
climate protection the Greens
fundamental issue is now a hot topic for
people from all walks of life so are the
former eco warriors on their way to
becoming Germany's next major party
there we are that's the question in the
next major party they're talking about
what you were talking about Volcom
battle about these folks part I'll just
give us another idea so that our viewers
really understand how elementary that
has been for German politics and explain
why the Greens cannot be in your
estimation of folks part I a big tent
party folks cotton played a major role
in the second half of the 20th century
but till then we see a steep decline and
they are important for heterogeneous
societies to keep them to keep it
together on a political level and they
can only do it if they draw voters
across all social classes across all age
cohorts and all cultural middle years
and this is not what the Greens are
prepared to do they may exploit more and
more this milieu of cosmopolitanism we
find in urban area they will gain a lot
of votes from the younger people but
they will not get so many votes from the
people above 60 which is a major share
of our electorate is right we do have
farm millions of somewheres living in
Germany and not only anywhere the Green
Party's is addressing so I think we we
do have a deep divided society but the
differences between us somewhere in
anyway educated who can't live
everywhere in the world who is mobile
and who is quite open to any forms of
living on social States and things like
that somewhere people who are in most
time live live on the countryside have a
job have a family and want to stay there
there want to stay somewhere have their
home somewhere so there millions of
somewheres living in Germany and they
are not as attracted by the Green Party
is be anywhere so I think that this is
one one problem the other one is the
society is divided even in Germany and
in a divided society you won't find
political parties which cover the whole
the whole electorate Maxie you say in
the quote to the top of the show the
Greens must choose between purity and
breaths tell me a little bit more about
that because we've seen how the greens
have been trying to branch out in the
last couple of years they've been trying
to get to the somewheres of to a certain
extent being successful in two other age
groups they have moved into other areas
of society lower-income areas it's it is
possible now for a nurse or a bus driver
to be a to be a green voter the
interesting thing is if we look
especially on the German state level
like if we don't try to see it in the
federal and the broader Germans
perspective but on the regional
perspectives how they learn to cater to
different needs in different German
regions so again coming back to the
spectacular example of last year's
election in Bavaria we've seen that the
Conservative Party the CSU in Bavaria
and the Social Democrats were both going
very heavy on the immigration issue they
were both majorly putting the campaign
on that card and they failed miserably
both the greens but broadening out their
campaign much more they were campaigning
on a lot of different issues that not
are not nationally Green issue they're
campaigning also on the challenge of
agriculture which you would think they
would normally do with organic angle
they didn't they were talking a lot
about the issues of conventional
agriculture something they on the state
level green the Green Party does turn to
conservative issues preservation of
creation and things like that and
addressing Christians addressing people
who are quite conservative and in their
mind I think despite the fact that they
according to you Ursula have struggled
to embrace intellectually the market
economy struggled more than any other
part of you say yeah this is the
economic part of green politicians they
as an opposition party they just chose
and picked small issues like
fireworks on New Year's Eve or sugar in
in lemonade's and the endings Lebec and
just went on these issues only to fight
too much sugar too much things of
everything and that is contrary to the
understanding of social market economy
you you put only frame economy and the
market and not not go for special issues
and the Green Party is the party which
is most keen on intervening in in small
topics and not just giving a frame and
let the market go within this frame well
I mentioned an important point the
creams are in opposition and if a
partner party is in opposition it can
claim some purity of its stance of its
program if you if they have to go into
government they have to make trade-offs
trade-offs between the environment to do
that in places like Hesse and in places
like Barton thought this is a quite
different thing because somewhere in the
state they do not decide about economic
policies not about tax policies not very
much about labor market policies but
these are the areas where the trade-offs
will come up between clear environmental
policy in these kind of policies for
seven years in German government are
from 1992 very much right they were not
punished about this but getting an
interest for these topics though
especially fiscal policy I thought was
quite an interesting to see that on a
governmental on a federal level the
Greens have now proposed to attack one
of the holy principles of the grand
coalition the black zero I mean we've
seen a policy proposal to interest in
the greens and this is something we have
would have expected from the Social
Democrats by the grains to say we need
to address the investment gap we need to
go away from the black zero policy and
we need to think about
structural investments in our
infrastructure in our telecommunications
networks and we need to find a different
policy for this and the name for that
policy is deficit spending yes it is and
and that is it came from the European
level down trickle down to the to the
German level and I think that the fiscal
competence of Green Party mainly is on
the European level and not so much on
the German level but on the other hand
it is the only party which is which is
prepared to stop the black zero and I'm
not so sure whether this is something
many people in Germany would agree to
but the Social Democrats already
recognized that this black zero never
have been a traditional social
democratic policy not democratic
policies so the Social Democratic
Finance defendant they will recognize
that this does harm to the party and
they will change in these issues
hopefully because they react to the
other main competitors and I'm pretty
much sure that this black zero which has
never been very welcomed among the rank
and files and the functionaries of the
party will be one of the first
sacrifices of the Social Democratic
parties to catch up again if being
argumentative to go for for the SPD zone
so it would be an argument for the Left
Party or for for the minute for the
greens house it's bigger now to address
these issues to not shy away they're not
shying away from issues of security
policy either their Security's policy
speaker on the federal level in the
German parliament
Agnieszka Braga she is being very
outspoken of like challenging the ideas
the Greens have been thinking about
security policies it used to be a very
pacifist approach in the kind of left
tradition and they're now becoming much
more realistic they're still staying and
this is this is the point I think it
will be interesting to see where on
these hard issues that define as
German politics will they make a
decision for their principles versus
their broader appeal or can they make
the principles broader and economic
policies or in social policy it is
mainly storytelling it is not as
detailed and as reliable as you tilted
for for the interiors and security
policies nevertheless Ursula T said that
the Greens have a very impressive
skillful well briefed knowledgeable
leadership duo neither of them had to
have have to govern a state or a city or
whatever so we don't know how they would
deliver if they were in responsibility
and Hobart havoc said well we have to
deliver know now and he has to prove
that the trade offs begins and this will
do harm to the more also talks and
purists among their voters just come
back to that point I didn't assume that
when I listed the qualifications for
leadership of the the German of the
green tenderly you were going to say yes
of course but professor matter did they
do the two green co-leaders have are
they chancellorship material this is not
as potential here now from the studios
that do not have experiences and they
should have some experiences I cannot
think about one bundeskanzler in our
history which who did not have
experiences in directing executives and
they have not been at the top of of land
in Germany and even this is something
which is so different from governing in
the federal system so I'm doubtful and I
would say both have to collect
experiences as well but on the other
hand I do not think that they become the
strongest party in the next and I think
you have to admit that bundeskanzler the
job you just grow with the positions if
you look at him would call
Angela Merkel in their first year but
but in their first years it was not not
every time joy just to watch them and to
experience their kind of leadership the
question is even if these two candidates
or these two party leaders are going to
be the actual candidates because I mean
what we've seen now they've always been
leading that party leaders have been
leading these campaigns but obviously
never was the intention of one of them
becoming a lead candidate for an actual
job because it's two people and they're
campaigning together now the natural
assumption is that Robert Harvick the
charismatic male leader would become it
and there's already been talks about
well shouldn't maybe the woman and Alena
bear book becoming the candidate I think
it's quite interesting and more
intelligent and she's for example
academically more qualified she studied
international law he has studied some
liberal arts and just talk about these
things there is fine distinctions but
the question is doesn't even have to be
one of the two of them they have now a
significant amount of members
high-ranking quite popular members their
executive experience on the European or
on the state are the most popular and to
some extent the electoral success of the
greens can be traced back probably more
to Harbach and I'm hesitating to say
this as a man in public so he is a real
popular figure and why are you
hesitating to say it
yeah because it could be the classical
male chauvinist of a white owned man
here this is a reason but I do think she
is probably even for German standards
too young for it this is another reason
aged 38 at this point in time is she I
think that's it I think so yeah Robert
are back just about touching 50 yeah
even 38 there will be a discussion in
turn you mentioned the word you
mentioned the word charisma and clearly
a lot of German votes I don't think this
is just press hi
I think a lot of people really out there
on the streets watching that TV programs
are very impressed by Robert Harvick
they are yeah they find him a compelling
they find him a charismatic figure but I
warn you again we've seen this it's it's
interesting to see it in direct
comparison through the Social Democrats
which have a lot of prominent popular
figures or like pop not so popular
anymore but a lot of prominent figures
of them on the national level that
several Germans like the Germans know we
have from the party leader to the
cabinet ministers to the heads of the
states with the Greens it's quite
interesting that they always seem to be
concentrated on several small figures
like the party leadership or maybe now
we do know also the head of the
parliamentary groups but it's
interesting to see I'm coming back to
Bavaria because it was very interesting
it was a it was an almost copy of an
Elena bear book and rubber topic that
was running the campaign there it was
Ludwig Hartmann and mr. Salter and they
they were quite the same team and in the
end it was clear at that point that if
they would be able to lead a government
it would be the male candidate because
they had already sorted out the
qualifications he was the more qualified
person and that's why I'm coming back to
principle versus appeal they need to
find their decisions before they appeal
with them to the voters they need to
make these decisions now and this is
something that needs to be happening not
based on polls but needs to based on
their own convictions because they are a
party that is very much about
convictions about policies they started
as a party that was sure only based on
the ecological purpose you fancy
essentially fanciers once they then have
an internal discussion who would be the
candidate which brings most of the
voters to the party they will also opt
for the most popular figure of the party
and then this is a matter of Appeal and
parties are about what maximizing what's
going to happen next all I think that
discussions within the Green Party on
fiscal policies and social policies on
all these issues you have to address if
you
to become a governing party and trouble
probably a party which has the chance to
be bonus counselor they have to sort it
out now and they have to sort out who is
not only the most popular popular but
also the most prominent and the most
intelligent person to go for it there's
also a point think about the Queen's
step into government they start with
their measures against climate change
which is absolutely right and correct
but we all know it will not change the
climate Germany is only responsible for
2 to 3 percent of the carbon emission so
they will not change anything and the
people will expect successes but they
cannot trap it a shock of reality for
the green voters as well ok with the
shock on shock of reality that's all
we're going to have to leave it thank
you very much for joining me here today
on quadriga we'd be talking about
Germany's potential new number one the
Greens
a lot of skepticism in the room about
that prospect bye-bye come back next
week just
[Music]